قبل الاعلان عن رد حماس الجانب
الاسرائيلي تحدث عن ان الضغط العسكري وا
القصف هو ما سيؤدي الى نجاح هذه
الصفقه كما تريدها اسرائيل ولكن الواضح ان
يعني قدرات حماس ما
زالت كما هي وتقاتل لمده اربعه اشهر وهي
يعني يبدو انها هي من تريد ان تفرض
ارادتها في صفقه مقبله وبالتالي السؤال
الان كيف ستتعامل
اسرائيل حينما يصل بلينكن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي وفي جعبته رد حماس الذي وصفته
القياده القطريه هنا بانه رد
ايجابي نعم يعني اخي جمال واضح جدا انه
بالنسبه لاسرائيل هذه الشعارات التي تحدثت
بها التي قالتها اسرائيل شعارات فشلت على
ارض الواقع وكل اسرائيلي حتى اليمين
المتطرف يفهم انه فشلت هذه الشعارات ولا
يمكن تحقيق هذه الشعرات عن طريق القوه لا
يمكن الوصول الى صفقه لانقاذ الاسرى
الاسرائيليين عن طريق القوه لا للدبابه
ولا للطياره صحيح الدبابه والطياره
الاسرائيليه قتلت الاف الاطفال
الفلسطينيين ودمرت يعني الاف البيوت
الفلسطينيه ولكنها لن تستطيع وهذا باعتراف
124 عسكري من كبار العسكريين الاسرائيليين
هذا انه اسرائيل لن تستطيع تحقيق اهدافها
عن طريق القوه اذا طريق التفاوض والان ما
يعني انا اريد ان الفت النظر الى
انه حينما يعني قررت حماس الرد اليوم
وتاخير الرد الى مده من الزمن كانت تتوقع
كل وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه ان ياتي
الرد بعد ساعه بعد ساعتين بعد يوم بعد
يومين في داخل اسرائيل خلال تاخير الرد
حصل نقاش كبير جدا وهذا النقاش الكبير
الذي حصل داخل اسرائيل عمليا وضع حماس على
الطاوله وهي الفئه الوحيده التي كانت على
طاوله النقاش الاسرائيليه خلال الاسبوع
الفائد هذا شيء مهم جدا ولذلك حينما وصل
الرد اليوم الى قطر ومن ثم بلينكن قال انه
يعني هو يتحدث عن المصطلح الذي عمله هدنه
ممتده هذا مصطلح لافت جدا هدنه ممتده حتى
حماس تحدثت عنها في الماضي هدنه مدتها ع
سنوات بس فقط لتوضيح حماس قالت وقف اطلاق
نار شامل
وتام نعم نعم كلامك 100% استاذ جمال صحيح
ولكن انا اتحدث في الماضي استعمل هذا
المصطلح حتى من قبل حماس ليعبر عن وقف
يعني مصطلح لوقف اطلاق النار يعني مصطلح
اخر لوقف اطلاق النار حماس في ردها اليوم
طبعا قالت انه وقت كامل لاطلاق النار ولكن
الاسرائيل الان سيبحث عن مخارج كيف يكون
اطلاق النار هذا وسيقبل في النهايه حسب
تقديري وقف كامل لاطلاق النار ووقف الحرب
لانه لا طريقه اخرى امامه وهل سيقبل برايك
دكتور يزبك ب ايضا ما اشار اليه بيان حماس
الهدف من هذا الرد الذي قالت بانه صاغته ب
يعني وكان ايجابيا قالت بانه يضمن وقف
اطلاق النار الشامل والتام انهاء العدوان
على الشعب الفلسطيني في غزه وبما يضمن
الاغاثه والايواء والاعمار ورفع الحصار عن
قطاع غزه وانجاز عمليه تبادل اسرى نريد ان
نفهم منك دكتور يزبك يعني هذه المحددات
التي
قدمتها حماس ووصفت بانها ايجابيه هل ستقبل
في داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه المتطرفه في
اسرائيل طبعا هذه المحددات التي حددتها
حماس هي يعني في منها انيه حاليه وفي منها
على مد على مدى فتره من الزمن وفيما ل
والمحدد الاول والاساسي هو وقف اطلاق
النار وعدم العوده لاطلاق النار سم يعني
فل تسميها اسرائيل مده هدنه مم متده هدنه
غير ممتده المهم انه يكون في هنالك وقف
حقيقي لق لمده ولا ولا عوده لاطلاق النار
وقف الحرب بكلمات كيف تتم الصياغه ليس
القضيه هنا والان يعني طبعا حينما وصلت
الاجابه ل حكومه قطر مباشره قام وزير
الخارجيه قطر ورئيس الحكومه وبلينك بارسال
الاجابه مباشره لاسرائيل يعني الان
الاجابه موجوده في اسرائيل تتداولها
الحكومه الاسرائيليه او مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي وهنالك
تعليقات دون اسماء في الصحافه الاسرائيليه
يعني خلال الساعه الاخيره كان مجموعه من
التعليقات التي اطلعت عليها ولم يذكروا
اسماء المعلقين طبعا هذا مفهوم ولكن الروح
العامه في هذه التعليقات اذا ما اقرا ما
بين السطور واقرا النصوص بشكل صحيح سيكون
غدا نوع من او خلال الليل نوع من رفض رفض
ض يعني ولكن رفض على مستحه دعنا نقول ولكن
يعني هنالك في مظاهره حاليا تحدث في تل
ابيب وهه مظاهره جديده لاهالي الاسرى
الاسرائيليين يضغطون بقبول وقف الحرب
وتحرير الاسرى